so wir kommen zum nächsten thema august
2021 die bilder gingen um die welt
menschen fielen von flugzeugen
versuchten sich verzweifelt festzuhalten
zehntausende afghaninnen und afghanen
versuchten fluchtartig ihr land zu
verlassen eine teils chaotische
evakuierungsaktion nach ende des
internationalen militäreinsatzes in
afghanistan
war das im koalitionsvertrag hatten die
ampel parteien festgehalten dass das
aufgearbeitet werden soll also diese
evakuierungs mission mit einem
parlamentarischen untersuchungsausschuss
eigentlich sollte der ende märz bereits
eingesetzt werden das verzögert sich
allerdings noch heute wird hier
debattiert über einen solchen
parlamentarischen untersuchungsausschuss
auf antrag der afg fraktion die eben
einen entsprechenden beschluss
einbringen will einen solchen
untersuchungsausschuss
einzusetzen
[Applaus]
rené springer spricht für die afg damen
und herren liebe gäste liebe soldaten
und veteranen die vielleicht zu schauen
die alternative für deutschland hier im
deutschen bundestag beantragt hier heute
die einsetzung eines
untersuchungsausschusses zur
aufarbeitung des einsatzes in
afghanistan
der 2001 von rot-grün begonnen wurde von
vier weiteren
bundesregierungen getragen wurde und
2021 in einem desaster endete kein
einziges ziel wurde erreicht
afghanistan wurde in ein chaos gestürzt
was waren die ziele der bundesregierung
das hauptziel war die aufrechterhaltung
der sicherheit und die schaffung einer
sich selbsttragenden stabilität sagt es
dass die anzahl der terror toten im
laufe der zeit und unter präsenz der
westlichen truppen jahr für jahr
gestiegen ist im jahr 2007 gab es
beispielsweise 2000 terror tote im jahr
8600 terror tote eine vervierfachung
2016 war der blutzoll der afghanischen
streitkräfte so groß dass die
afghanische regierung und die us
regierung beschlossen haben die zahlen
nicht mehr zu veröffentlichen und die
bundesregierung hat sich dieser
täuschung strategie angeschlossen
insgesamt sind von 2001 bis 2002 21
212.000 tote zu beklagen das ist das
ergebnis werte geleitete außenpolitik
bei der der werte export und die
demokratisierung wichtiger waren als die
realität vor ort die kulturelle
identität der afghanen und der tradition
dieser menschen wir waren in den augen
vieler afghanen keine befreiung wir
waren besatzer
ein westlicher
ein westlicher fremdkörper in eine
archaische stammeskultur und damit
selbst ein faktor für die zunehmende
instabilität in diesem land ein weiteres
ziel der bundesregierung war die
förderung von rechtsstaatlichkeit
demokratie und frauenrechte ein
wissenschaftliches gutachten das wird
doch den dienst des bundestages sagt
jetzt einen funktionierenden rechtsstaat
hat es in afghanistan im jahr 2001 bis
2021 nie gegeben
afghanistan war spätestens seit 2010 de
facto ein gescheiterter staat die
taliban gewannen die oberhand damit auch
korruption drogen ökonomie und medizin
willkür doch die bundesregierung
verbreitete noch zehn weitere lange
jahre durchhalte parolen und gaukelte
der öffentlichkeit eine verbesserung der
lage vor die es vor ort nicht gab und
was ist mit den frauenrechten
heute ist die burka man liest es in die
zeitungen wieder pflicht für frauen die
reisefreiheit von frauen ohne männliche
begleitung wird begrenzt mädchen dürfen
keine weiteren keine weiterführenden
schulen mehr besuchen das ist das
ergebnis für minister außenpolitik
die bundesregierung hat das ziel
verfolgt
drogenanbau in afghanistan zu bekämpfen
das ziel das aufgerufen wurde war die
halbierung der drogenanbau flächen
tatsächlich ist die opiumproduktion von
2001 im letzten jahr der
taliban-herrschaft bis 2021 um das 36
fache gestiegen
36 mal mehr drogenproduktion obwohl man
den kampf gegen drogen ausgerufen hat
afghanistan ist heute der haupt drogen
produzent der haupt opium produzent
weltweit und versorgt 24 drogen von 24
millionen drogenkonsumenten 80 prozent
aller nutzer
2021 war afghanistan auch zweitgrößter
haschisch produzent der welt kein bürger
versteht wie man den kampf gegen drogen
ausrufen kann und dann entsteht dort ein
staat der sich zum global player in der
drogen union arbeitet kein mensch
versteht dass
ein weiteres ziel der bundesregierung
war afghanischer sicherheitskräfte zu
befähigen sicherheit im eigenen land zu
gewährleisten
2003 lag die zahl der afghanischen
streitkräfte bei 6.000 2020 bei
272.000 die streitkräfte umfasst mehr
truppen und polizisten als die
bundeswehr und trotzdem konnten die
taliban nach dem abzug der westlichen
truppen truppen ohne auf nennenswerten
widerstand zu stoßen afghanistan zurück
erobern ergebnisse von 20 jahren
ausbildung ausrüstung finanzierung
trading sind binnen weniger tage
pulverisiert worden wie ist so etwas
möglich
meine damen und herren dieser trick
hatte viele verlierer aber auch gewinner
die verlierer sind die deutschen
steuerzahler die über 17 milliarden euro
bezahlt haben für diesen einsatz die
verlierer sind über 100.000 deutsche
soldaten die in diesem einsatz sinnlos
verheizt wurden die verlierer sind 59
getötete deutsche soldaten und tausende
mit einsatzbedingten psychischen
erkrankungen die heute noch damit zu
kämpfen haben und die profiteure das ist
die rüstungsindustrie die gute geschäfte
gemacht hat vor allem aber die taliban
die heute fester im sattel sitzen als
noch 2001 und extrem hoch gerüstet sind
durch unsere ausstattung und durch
unsere ausbildung es ergeben sich
unendlich viele fragen aus diesem
20-jährigen einsatz und diese fragen
wollen wir im rahmen eines
untersuchungsausschusses klären wie
konnten fünf bundesregierungen sich
selbst und die deutsche öffentlichkeit
zwei jahrzehnte lang täuschen warum
setzte die bundesregierung auf korrupte
warlords und kriegsverbrecher als
partner die nur interesse am eigenen
macht ausbau hatten aber nicht an
stabilität wie konnte es sein dass die
opiumproduktion unter westlicher präsenz
stets höher lag als unter der herrschaft
der taliban
warum hat sich die bundesregierung so
lange geweigert trotz der militärisch
aussichtslosen situation mit den taliban
gespräche zu führen wie es der damalige
chef kurt beck 2007 gefordert hat und
wie es letztlich von trump dem
us-präsidenten auch getan wurde wie viel
steuergeld ist in den händen korrupter
macht geliebten gelandet und vor allem
wie konnte eine ganze armee die größer
war als die bundeswehr innerhalb weniger
tage kollabieren diese fragen müssen aus
unserer sicht geklärt werden damit komme
ich zum schluss die aufarbeitung von 20
jahren afghanistan-einsatz wird
verwundete und traumatisierte soldaten
nicht heilen sie wird auch keinen der
getöteten drei polizisten und 59
getöteten soldaten zurückholen aber wir
sind es ihnen und ihren angehörigen
schuldig das desaster die falschen
entscheidungen die leeren versprechungen
die täuschungen die lügen schonungslos
aufzuklären
wir wollen und wir müssen die politisch
verantwortlichen zur rechenschaft ziehen
und das ist das ziel das wir mit diesem
antrag auf einsetzung eines
untersuchungsausschusses zu afghanistan
verfolgen ich bedanke mich für die
aufmerksamkeit das sagte rené springer
für die afg und das ist die grundlage
der heutigen debatte die ampel koalition
möchte ebenfalls einen parlamentarischen
untersuchungsausschuss
zu dieser in aktivierungs mission in
afghanistan noch ist er nicht eingesetzt
noch gibt es die vorlage nicht jetzt
hören wir mal was ralf stegner dazu zu
sagen hat mitglied im auswärtigen
ausschuss für die spd
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen nichts
ist gut in afghanistan so könnte man
fast wieder sagen im schatten der
ukraine krieges verschlechtert sich die
lage für die menschen täglich 95 prozent
der bevölkerung können sich nicht mehr
ausreichend ernähren besonders
dramatisch ist die situation für kinder
hinzu kommen massive gewalt gegen frauen
schwerste menschenrechtsverletzungen
geduldet oder veranlasst durch die
machthaber der taliban es ist unsere
verantwortung hier sofort und
unbürokratisch humanitäre hilfe zu
leisten
es wundert mich kein bisschen dass der
antrag der fdp die situation der
menschen mit keinem wort erwähnt da habt
ihr geht es nie um menschen die um
internationale zusammenarbeit und schon
gleich gar nicht um friedenssicherung
vier leitstellen bleibt der
nationalismus des vergangenen
jahrhunderts mit dieser rostigen
ideologie haben demokraten in diesem
hause nichts gemeinsam
wir haben meine lieben kollegen eine
verantwortung dafür dass das deutsche
engagement in afghanistan aufgearbeitet
wird viele haben alle gemacht die
nationale gemeinschaft die afghanischen
regierungen noch wir nach sage und
schreibe 20 jahren afghanistan-einsatz
der bundeswehr und deutsche
entwicklungszusammenarbeit müssen wir
daraus für zukünftige auslandseinsätze
lernen und diese mal ausrichten das ist
mit dem denken bei ihnen nicht soweit
hefti habe ich ja schon ausgeführt
leider klappt es nicht mal mit dem lesen
hätten sie den koalitionsvertrag der spd
mit grünen und fdp gelesen wüssten sie
nämlich wir werden einen
parlamentarischen untersuchungsausschuss
sowie eine enquetekommission einsetzen
wir werden im juni
gemeinsam in der demokratischen
opposition im untersuchungsausschuss auf
den weg bringen doch wir brauchen wir
hier ein antrag nicht das ist ein
bisschen länger gedauert hat ist der
kriegssituation der ukraine geschuldet
was jeder nachvollziehen kann der über
ein bisschen urteilsvermögen verfügt das
tun sie ja bekanntermaßen nicht ihre
heldenhaften aufklärer pose bedarf es
also auch diesmal nicht und übrigens
kann ihr antrag auch nicht verdecken
dass die politische rechte kein konzept
für eine zeitgemäße europäische außen-
und sicherheitspolitik hat wenn sie
ihren fragenkatalog auf denen sie so
stolzen nicht wegwerfen wollen kleiner
tipp von mir stellen sich die fragen
untersuchungsausschuss nehmen wir
einrichten haben werden sie beantwortet
wer wirklich etwas lernen will
verzichtet besser auf vorgezogene
schlussfolgerung auch das
disqualifiziert über die heutige
debatten grundlage die ampel koalition
bekennt sich zu ihrer verantwortung die
deutsche außenpolitik an unseren werten
von frieden und freiheit der
europäischen zusammenarbeit im
prinzipien des völkerrechts auszurichten
dazu gehört immer auch eine kritische
auseinandersetzung mit den
auslandseinsätzen unserer
parlamentsarmee im deutschen bundestag
in seiner zeitenwende hat der
bundeskanzler angekündigt dass wir mit
dem sondervermögen von 100 milliarden
euro endlich für die anständige und
zeitgemäße ausrüstung unserer
soldatinnen und soldaten
bei der landes und die verteidigung aber
auch bei den auslandseinsätzen sorgen
werden menschen dürfen niemals beliebige
figuren auf dem schachbrett von
großmacht oder ressourcen interessen
werden daher müssen auslandseinsätze an
denen die bundeswehr sich beteiligt
immer dem ziel die ihm den frieden zu
sichern oder zu schaffen und humanitäre
hilfe zu leisten
außenpolitische konflikte lassen sie
haben ende niemals militärisch lösen die
zeitenwende verlangt eine neuordnung
unserer außen- und sicherheitspolitik
wir werden in den nächsten monaten über
komplexe fragen von sicherheit
demokratie globaler gerechtigkeit
rüstungskontrolle einen neuen
friedensordnung in dem völkerrecht
entspricht unter kommunität reden müssen
lassen sie mich im namen der ist für die
bundestagsfraktion noch einmal unseren
soldatinnen und soldaten den zivilen
entwicklungsexperten experten und den
vielen menschen vor ort danken sie haben
im auftrag des deutschen bundestags mit
ihren partnern viele jahre dafür gesorgt
dass zeitweise sehr wohl beträchtliche
fortschritte eingetreten sind bei der
rechtsstaatlichkeit bei den
bildungschancen für mädchen bei
frauenrechten bei infrastrukturaufbau
terrorismusbekämpfung gerade von unseren
programmen für berufliche bildung haben
viele tausend menschen profitiert die
gelernten fähigkeiten werden noch in
jahrzehnten für afghanistan von
bedeutung sein auch wenn der einsatz
unmöglich zu ende gegangen ist das
bleibt meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren und die furchtbaren bilder vom
abzug aus afghanistan sind unser
allgegenwärtig die willkür der taliban
die unterdrückung vieler menschen vor
allem von frauen und mädchen ist
unerträglich und täglich erreichen uns
auch anfragen verzweifelter menschen die
das land aus angst um ihr leben
verlassen müssen nichts ist gut in
afghanistan da trotzdem nur ein teil der
wahrheit das ende der afghanistan
mission bedeutet im umkehrschluss nicht
dass unser einsatz für frieden mit
anderen partnern umsonst oder falsch
gewesen wäre einfache antworten sind nie
richtig eine moderne außen und
sicherheitspolitik ist anspruchsvoller
als die schwarzweiß debatten in social
media blasen der untersuchungsausschuss
und die angeht kommission bieten uns die
gelegenheit gemeinsam mit den
demokratischen parteien dieses hauses
konstruktiv daran zu arbeiten aus
fehlern zu lernen und unser fan von sich
reden mehr als sie denken sollten wir
werden unserer verantwortung gerecht
werden dafür dass zukünftig besser zu
machen den antrag der rechtsradikalen
nehmen ja vielen dank
stegner ob man im unterausschuss
abrüstung rüstungskontrolle und
nichtverbreitung hier mit seiner rede
auf in folge norbert röttgen er mitglied
im auswärtigen ausschuss
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
zunächst ein wort zum antrag der
fdp-fraktion der antrag zeigt dass ihre
fraktion entweder das instrument des
untersuchungsausschusses nicht
verstanden hat oder dass dir oder dass
ihre fraktion des missbräuchlich
einsetzt im zentrum eines
untersuchungsausschusses steht die
beweisaufnahme
es geht um sachverhalts ermittlung
allein darum geht es es geht um
sachverhalts entwicklung tatsachen
ermitteln und nicht agitationen können
sie hier betreiben können sie sonst wo
betreiben aber dafür ist nicht das
instrument des untersuchungsausschusses
und gehen so kann kann ich nicht noch
nicht einmal der empfehlung des kollegen
stegner anschließen dass sie ihre fragen
die sie dort formuliert haben im
untersuchungsausschuss stellen denn alle
diese fragen wären unzulässig si der
untersuchungs auf das sage ich weil der
untersuchungsausschuss hat eine ganz
spezifische einzigartige funktion hat er
kann wie ein richter mit richterlichen
befugnissen beweise erheben kann sogar
vereidigen dh doch muss vorgegangen
werden wie zu gericht es müssen die
beweise gestellt werden nach den
anforderungen der strafprozessordnung
das typische an ihren fragen ist dass
sie mit ihrer frage immer schon gleich
die wertung und bewertung vornehmen kein
richter in diesem land dürfte könnte
würde solche fragen stellen sie sind
unzulässig darum ist ein formal ihr
ganzer antrag
unzulänglich und er zeigt dass es
überhaupt kein bemühen gibt sich mit
dieser dramatischen lage
auseinanderzusetzen
das möchte ich in der verbleibenden zeit
kurz tun denn ich bin davon überzeugt
dass es aus dem afghanistan-einsatz
lehren zu ziehen gibt
und wir als fraktion wie andere
fraktionen sind auch der auffassung dass
etwas aufzuarbeiten ist
und ich möchte mich auf eine lehre und
einen gegenstand der aufarbeitung hier
beziehen die nicht benennen möchte
das was mich umtreibt und ich nutze die
gelegenheit ihr zu sagen dass mich bis
dahin selten in der politik etwas so
wütend und traurig gemacht hat wie das
ergebnis des abzuges der nato-truppen
aus afghanistan
denn seitdem die nato nicht mehr in
afghanistan ist
seitdem die nato nicht mehr in
afghanistan ist ist in dieses land
terror
chaos und elend zurückgekehrt das ist
die folge des abzugs der nato die
taliban sind zurückgekehrt es herrscht
eine fürchterliche hungersnot
fürchterlich der unfähigkeit und dem
chaos des taliban-regimes geschuldet
mädchen können eben nicht mehr auf die
schule gehen frauen können kein
selbstbestimmtes leben mehr führen die
scharia und angewendet in dem chaos
dieses landes
das ist das ergebnis
der entscheidung dass die nato abgezogen
ist als die nato da war war eine zeit
von freiheit und selbstbestimmung und
stabilität in afghanistan seit langen
und jahrzehnten nicht mehr erlebt hatte
das war die realität
und wir müssen uns noch mit damit
beschäftigen wie wir diesen lieber den
genau es das ist wieder die gewohnte
übereinstimmung von afg und
linksfraktion in der außenpolitik
absolut übereinstimmung sie sind der
meinung die nadel ist schuld ich bin der
meinung das problem ist dass die nato
nicht mehr da ist und das ist ja
empirisch bewiesen weil vorher weil
vorher in einem ausmaß stabilität und
freiheit und selbstbestimmung
möglichkeit war und jetzt haben wir es
wieder zurück also müssen wir doch
fragen was ist falsch gelaufen
wie konnte es dazu kommen
sie meinen es war weil die nato da war
ich sage es ist weil die nato nicht mehr
dabei warum ist die nato nicht mehr da
die nato ist nicht mehr dabei präsident
tom so entschieden hat america first das
ist nicht mehr unser interesse und er
hat mit den taliban verhandelt und
selbst diese verhandlungen ob studiert
dadurch dass er einfach einen
abzugstermin genannt hat die taliban
mussten nicht mal verhandeln sie mussten
nur abwarten
dann kam der amtswechsel präsident biden
und er hat im wesentlichen mit einer
vier monatigen verzögerung diese politik
dieses dieses größte desaströse erbe nur
fortsetzen können und die amerikaner
sind abgezogen die europäer wussten das
ist falsch der europäer wussten es ist
falsch aber wir wussten auch wir sind
nicht in der lage
unsere interessen zu vertreten das
außenpolitisch zu tun was wir für
richtig halten weil wir die
möglichkeiten die militärischen
möglichkeiten dazu nicht haben das ist
die lehre und die erfahrung wenn sie mal
ihr dummes gerede für eine halbe minute
einstellen könnten wäre ich ihnen
dankbar sie haben außer dienst
er muss weiter tragen können und das
wird sich auch deshalb weil ich hier nur
das elend von menschen rede und sie
haben nichts anderes im sinn als ihre
dummen parteipolitischen sprüche zu
einer beleidigung verhöhnung von
tausenden ganz klar denken
auffassung dass wir schon gesagt das
terrain das zwischenrufen nicht der
geschäftsführung deutsche bundestags
entspricht noch nicht wirklich
sonderlich intelligent ist wenn sie was
zu sagen war dann behältnisse ich lasse
den kurzen weg schon mal gerne zu wenn
sie das wollen aber den redner durch
dauerndes zwischenrufen zu stören ist
einfach stillos
[Applaus]
wir müssen uns
mit der europäischen ohnmacht
beschäftigen die wir erlebt haben der
amerikanische rückzug hat am rand
europäische ohnmacht sichtbar gemacht
für die amerikaner ist das ein ozean
weit entfernt diese region wird auch
nicht mehr priorität der interessen der
amerikaner werden aber es ist aus ängste
und untrennbar mit der sicherheit und
stabilität in europa verbunden wie es in
der region in zentralasien und nord und
im nahen und mittleren osten aussieht
dass es die lehre die wir ziehen müssen
um unserer sicherheit willen und auch
unserer verantwortung für die menschen
dort wir dürfen wegen unserer eigenen
interessen und wegen unserer
verantwortung europäische ohnmacht nicht
weiter dulden wir müssen entschieden und
selber befähigen unsere eigenen
interessen zu vertreten meine damen und
herren um das zweite ist das ist die art
und weise des rückzugs unsere ohnmacht
hat sich bis in die art und weise des
rückzugs ja am ende fast der
fluchtartigen des fluchtartigen abzugs
aus afghanistan
gezeigt ich selber bin angerufen wurden
von eltern und schulleitungen von
kindern und schülern die in afghanistan
waren deutsche schüler afghanischer
abstammung die zu denen es kein kontakt
gab wir haben menschen zurückgelassen
die mit denen wir kooperiert haben und
das muss aufgeklärt werden warum waren
wir auf den schlechten verlauf der dinge
nicht vorbereitet wer hat wie agiert die
koordination so etwas darf nicht mehr
passieren und bevor wir zu den wertungen
kommen müssen wir den sachverhalt und
die tatsachen ermitteln seriöse das ist
unsere verantwortung wir wollen dieser
verantwortung gerecht werden die cdu csu
fraktion ist in guten gesprächen mit den
koalitionsfraktionen
um den sachverhalt zu ermitteln und zu
ermitteln was ist falsch gelaufen es ist
unsere verantwortung lehren und
konsequenzen zu ziehen das ist das gebot
der stunde den wollen wir folgen vielen
dank
norbert röttgen macht hier auf die lage
in afghanistan aufmerksam auch die
bundeskanzlerin die ehemalige hat ja
dort schon fehleinschätzung der lage in
dem land eingeräumt und so auch der
außenminister zu der zeit heiko mass an
ihren bruder spricht jetzt für die
grünen-fraktion und kollegen sehr
geehrter herr präsident mit ihrer
erlaubnis zitiere ich wir sind dann erst
mal nur per telefon zu erreichen wir
zerstören die it schönen sonntag noch
ende
das sind die letzten worte die im august
2021 aus der deutschen botschaft ans
auswärtige amt gekabelt wurden danach
machte sich der stellvertretende
botschafter mit seinen verbliebenen und
mitarbeiter innen auf den weg zum
flughafen es waren dramatische stunden
in kabul das von den taliban überrannt
wurde es war auch das brutale ende eines
sehr langen und schwierigen
bundeswehreinsatzes lassen sie mich
vorweg schicken als abgeordnete die die
einsätze der bundeswehr in afghanistan
immer sehr kritisch gesehen hat möchte
ich zunächst allen soldatinnen
diplomatischen und zivilen helferinnen
und all den menschen in afghanistan
danke die über jahre alles gegeben haben
um das leben der menschen dort zu
verbessern und ihnen dramatischen
stunden des abzuges alles getan haben um
so viele menschen wie möglich zu retten
und den schaden
überheblichen und pseudo belehrenden ton
den die wir hier von rechts gehört haben
den findig abschluss absolut deplatziert
in dieser wichtigen debatte
ich meinte die rede des kollegen mit der
eingefangen hat ja es gab sehr viel
meine damen und herren auf das wir
kritisch zurück blicken mussten zu einem
auf das deutsche und internationale
engagement der letzten 20 jahre und zum
anderen auf den chaotischen abzug und
die frage warum eine evakuierung von
staatsbürgern von personal von orts
kräften und besonders gefährdeten
gruppen nicht viel sorgfältiger
vorbereitet wurde warum menschen die
unser engagement in afghanistan
unterstützt haben ausharren mussten
obwohl sie schon vor jahren anträge
gestellt haben weil sie bedroht waren
das bleibt diesen menschen zu helfen
nach wie vor eine sehr wichtige aufgabe
und koalitionsvertrag haben wir
vereinbart und mit der genehmigung des
präsidenten zitiere ich wir wollen die
evakuierungs mission des afghanistan
einsatzes in einem parlamentarischen
untersuchungsausschuss aufarbeiten zudem
wollen wir den gesamteinsatz in einer in
kat kommission mit wissenschaftlicher
expertise evaluieren die gewonnenen
erkenntnisse müssen praxisnah und
zukunftsgerichtet aufgearbeitet werden
so dass sie in die gestaltung
zukünftiger deutsche auslandseinsätze
einfließen und es ist nicht gewöhnlich
dass sie einen untersuchungsausschuss im
koalitionsvertrag von
regierungsfraktionen finden aber weil
diese fragen so ernst sind weiter abzugs
und dramatisch war haben sich hier
fraktionen demokratische fraktion aus
opposition und koalition zusammen getan
um eine ernsthafte debatte hinzubekommen
und ich kann ihnen versichern wir sind
gemeinsam in sehr guten gesprächen ohne
den brutalen angriffs krieg in der
ukraine wären wir schon so weit aber ich
bin gerade mit blick auf die letzten
drei monate sehr dankbar wie sachlich
konstruktiv wir in der ampel und auch
gemeinsam mit der union zusammenarbeiten
konnten das ist für mich auch gerade in
die in ernsten zeiten ausdruck eines
neuen politikstils jenseits dieser
virtuellen rollen die wir glaube ich
alle satt haben von regierungen oder
oppositionen und er sollte schule machen
die einzigen die versuchen aus dieser
ersten debatte eine peinliche show zu
machen sind die rechten hier am land sie
leben total überstürzt ein total
absurden antrag vor ist ja schon
exzellent versenkt wurden von herrn
stegner und drücken kann mich allem
anschließen und fordern einen
untersuchungsausschuss kommt zur
nächsten absurdität über 20 jahre ich
war selbst mitglied mehrerer
untersuchungsausschüsse und ich kann
ihnen sagen dass es ein mittel zur
aufklärung nicht zu abrechnungen es geht
darum konkrete fehler zu beleuchten
schlussfolgerungen für die zukunft zu
ziehen und verantwortung zu benennen sie
dagegen wollen dass sich ein
parlamentarischer untersuchungsausschuss
in deutschland unter anderem mit der
frage beschäftigt und das haben sie dann
noch zum anlass genommen ist hier im
plenum noch mal vorzutragen warum zitat
die opiumproduktion während der zeit
westlicher präsenz in afghanistan stets
höher war als in der regierungszeit des
taliban-regimes frage 22 mir ist bewusst
dass parlamentarische arbeit nicht ihre
stärke ist aber das ist selbst für die
afg weltfremd und
ökologischen fragen ob es nicht
ein untersuchungsausschuss ist übrigens
zu sehen extrem zeit- und
arbeitsintensiv das kann ich aus eigener
erfahrung bestätigen kurzer hinweis der
untersuchungsausschuss zur bombardierung
in kundus sagte knapp zwei jahre mit 339
aktenordnern da ging es um einen
zeitraum von wenigen wochen ein
untersuchungsausschuss der die von ihnen
aufgeworfenen fragen ernsthaft
bearbeiten würde würde jahrzehnte tragen
müssen man muss die akten dann noch
lesen aber umgehend es offensichtlich
nicht um erkenntnisse sondern um
effekthascherei
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der untersuchungsausschuss zum abzug und
die enc at zum engagement in afghanistan
sie stehen dafür dass wir die menschen
in afghanistan nicht vergessen haben
sondern auch nach dem abzug und auch
wenn die aufmerksamkeit weniger gegeben
ist hinschauen um zu unserer
verantwortung stehen und es sind wir
auch der bundeswehr schuldig gemeinsam
werden wir von den demokratischen
fraktionen zeigen dass politik sich
ihren fehlern stellen kann dass die
verantwortung übernimmt dass sie den
anspruch hat zu lernen und fehler der
vergangenheit nicht zu wiederholen
mit diesem antrag von rechts sehen wir
das genaue gegenteil davon und deshalb
freue ich mich dass wir ihnen bald einen
sehr klugen breit getragenen und
ernsthaften vorschlag vorlegen können
vielen dank
vielen dank frau kollegin broker die fdp
fraktion hat eine kurzinformation
beantragt ich gebe dem polieren kräuter
das wort stefan kreuzer ist das für die
fw fraktion
wir müssen hier mal mit einigen
fehlinformationen der vorher
gesprochenen fraktionen aufräumen es ist
ja vorgeworfen worden wir würden mit
unserem antrag gewisse wertung vornehmen
dem ist nicht so es braucht aber für die
einsetzung eines
untersuchungsausschusses gewisser
anfangs verdachtsmomente diese anfangs
verdachtsmomente hat mein kollege
springer benannt und darauf begründen
wir die einsetzung eines
untersuchungsausschusses frau bruder sie
hatten gerade eben gesagt sie haben
schon in untersuchungsausschüssen
teilgenommen dann müssten sie ja
eigentlich wissen dass dies kein die der
kollege röttgen auch schon sagte kein
gerichtsverfahren ist sondern ein
untersuchungsausschuss ist ein
politisches instrument ist zeigt
politisches versagen auch und es zeigt
staatsversagen auf und wenn wir sie sie
als regierungstragende fraktion alleine
machen lassen würden dann würde sich der
untersuchungszeitraum auf das ende
dieser munition in afghanistan und den
abzug verdichten da wo sie frau bruder
gerade eben auch zugesprochen haben viel
wichtig etwas für uns zu welchen
fehlleistungen der bundesregierung ist
in der zeit der kompletten mission
gekommen ist wie es dazu kommen konnte
dass bundespolizisten um kameradinnen
und kameraden der bundeswehr gefallen in
einem auslandseinsatz der für uns in
dieser form in keinster weise
nachvollziehbar war und da gehört auch
dazu warum die drogenproduktion in
afghanistan stärker wahr oder
erfolgreicher war als die ganzen jahre
ohne westliche militärpräsenz das in
sachverhaltes aufzuarbeiten gibt wir
möchten mit unserem antrag das den blick
dafür schärfen den untersuchungsauftrag
möglichst breit zu fassen um uns genau
diesem versagen zurück dazu widmen es
handelt sich um ein politisches
instrument und politische
verantwortlichkeiten aufzuzeigen oder
eine letzte information die uns auch
noch interessiert soll nach unseren
informationen pakistan 50.000 menschen
auf gepackten koffern sitzen die
sukzessive nach köln und nach leipzig
ausgeflogen werden nach den anfragen die
meiner fraktion in den letzten monat
angestellt hat dürften diese angehörigen
die über führungsanspruch haben
lediglich maximal arten der saison
gleich schluss bildet wagen wir uns wie
kommt es plötzlich zu 50.000 es gibt
sehr wohl was soll da kommen sie mit dem
zum schluss ja was wir auch zu arbeiten
ist dafür haben wir den antrag gestellt
wie gesagt wir möchten dieses politische
instrument weit fasst vielen dank bevor
sie antworten problem wo wir wenn sie es
war auch wollen welche kollegen darauf
hinweisen dass die sitzungsleitung hier
nicht mit vorsitzender so ein präsident
oder präsidentin angesprochen wird das
lernen sie aber wahrscheinlich auch noch
bis zum ende der legislaturperiode
ansonsten wären noch einmal darauf
hinweisen
über sie können an wurden
und ich weiß gar nicht wo ich anfangen
und wo ich auch von soll und ehrlich
gesagt mitglieder rede mit jedem
zwischenstufe und das rechnet dieser
kurzintervention offenbaren sie wirklich
in einer art und weise dass sie keinen
plan von und parlamentarischen
untersuchungsausschüssen haben wie die
funktionieren nach welchen regeln sie
funktioniert sehr gerade eine reihe von
kollegen nicken kollege strasser ja der
auch schon da erfahrungen hat also
wirklich das belohnt sich da gar nicht
einzusteigen der präsident würde mir gar
nicht so viel zeit an dieser stelle
geben und deshalb haben wir uns ja auch
als fraktionen die demokratisch sind und
ahnung haben gedanken gemacht wie wir
wirklich auch der verantwortung gerecht
werden können die 20 jahre
auslandseinsätze in afghanistan
aufzuarbeiten nochmals kundus einige
wochen
339 aktenordner zwei jahre tagen wir
saßen da jeden donnerstag bis teilweise
fünf uhr morgens in der nacht wie lange
wollen sie eigentlich einen
untersuchungsausschuss über 20 jahre für
das richtige mittel ist hier die in kat
kommission die mit wissenschaftlern mit
der bundeswehr mit sachverständigen mit
zivilgesellschaft und dem hohen
sachverstand aus dem demokratischen
fraktionen dieses hauses genau die
fragen aufarbeiten wird welche lehren
wir ziehen müssen nochmals lesen hilft
sowohl die geschäftsordnung des
bundestages die regeln des
untersuchungsausschusses der
koalitionsvertrag vielleicht ist das
besser investierte zeit als solche
wirklich grottigen anträge zu schreiben
von ihrer probe weist hier auch nochmal
auf die in kat kommission hin die jedes
den gesamteinsatz bewerten soll und
daraus dann auch leitlinien und lehrern
für andere sitz einsätze ableiten soll
der außenpolitische sprecher für die
linksfraktion spricht als nächstes
gregor gysi
herr präsident die wir kolleginnen und
kollegen der krieg in afghanistan war
von anfang an falsch die einzige
konsequente gegenstimme schon zu beginn
kam von der pds später auch von der
linken allerdings räume ich ein dass wir
beim antrag der regierung auf abzug der
bundeswehr und rettung von menschenleben
absolut daneben entschieden haben
nämlich mit ja nein und enthaltung
absurd wir hatten 20 jahre lang recht
und dann das nach dieser krieg hat es zu
keiner zeit die unterstützung der
mehrheit der bevölkerung unseres landes
zu keiner zeit sie haben 20 jahre lang
die mehrheitsmeinung der bevölkerung
ignoriert über 17 millionen euro sinnlos
ausgegeben das leben und die gesundheit
von soldatinnen und soldaten geopfert
den tod von afghanischen frauen männern
und kindern in kauf genommen man kann
mittels krieg nicht die soziale
religiöse staatliche entwicklung eines
landes umstritten auch nicht so gut die
taliban sind heute stärker denn je
nichts von dem was die bundeswehr dort
schaffen wollte hat bestand wann wollen
sie eigentlich die anderen einsätze
beenden weil wir jetzt grundsätzlich mal
darüber nachdenken müssen zum beispiel
kosovo 20 jahre 50 jahre 100 jahre nie
beziffern sie ein ende der einsätze das
streben der deutschen außenpolitik seit
dem völkerrechtswidrigen krieg gegen
jugoslawien
das internationale gewicht deutschlands
durch immer neue militär in
kriegseinsätze der bundeswehr zu erhöhen
hat sich mit dem fluchtartigen ende in
afghanistan endgültig als gescheitert
gewesen am schlimmsten aber es dass sie
nicht daraus lernen in mali wiederholt
sich das desaster die zweite
putschregierung dort lehnt wahlen ab
frankreich zieht seine truppen zurück
aber der bundestag soll morgen die
verlängerung bei der einsetzung
beschließen umso dringender wäre eine
gründliche und schonungslose
aufarbeitung der bundeswehr einst des
bundeswehreinsatzes in afghanistan
versprochen wurde dies noch von
bundeskanzlerin merkel auch im
koalitionsvertrag ist von einer
enquetekommission einem
untersuchungsausschuss und einer
interministeriellen arbeitsgruppe die
rede aber selbst ein dreiviertel jahr
nach dem ende des krieges gibt es nichts
davon spd grüne und fdp geben im verein
mit der union nun ausgerechnet der
rechtsaußen seite des hauses die
gelegenheit die große auf arbeiterin zu
geben
jene partei der ist mit der abschiebung
von menschen nach afghanistan trotz des
krieges nie schnell genug gehen konnte
und die auch heute kein problem damit
hat menschen in die taliban herrschaft
zu schicken jene partei geht mit der
gewaltsam abwehr von flüchtlingen
überhaupt keine probleme hat jene partei
die gerade versucht sich als friedens
bewegt zu inszenieren sie können niemals
teil der friedensbewegung sein weil sie
ein eine partei des unfriedens der
diskriminierung des hasses des rassismus
und des antisemitismus sind schon
deshalb muss man ihren antrag ablehnen
und zwar durch alle anderen fraktionen
des hauses
aber das ändert nichts daran dass man
der ampel koalition offensichtlich auf
die sprünge helfen muss damit dass
afghanistan die sache endlich
aufgearbeitet wird wir werden einen
besseren antrag einreichen es bleibt
eine dringende aufgabe den menschen zu
helfen die der bundeswehr geholfen haben
die sich zu demokratischen werten und
frauenrechten bekannten und bekennen
doch die bundesregierung hat es bisher
nicht einmal geschafft wenigstens alle
menschen in sicherheit zu bringen die
unmittelbar der bundeswehr gez und
anderen deutschen einrichtungen
zusammengearbeitet haben
diese hartherzige abwehrende umgang ist
eine schande für uns so wie wir menschen
helfen die aus der ukraine vor den
russischen angriffen fliehen so ist es
auch unsere pflicht den menschen zu
helfen die vor den taliban fliehen es
darf keine der flüchteten erster zweiter
und dritter klasse die bewegungs und
fraktion union wollen die gigantischste
aufrüstung in der bundesdeutschen
geschichte beschließen russland wird
deutschland nicht angreifen und wenn
doch wäre es ein bündnisfall usa
großbritannien frankreich und viele
andere müssen eingreifen und wir hätten
den dritten weltkrieg deshalb umgekehrt
nach dem krieg russlands gegen die
ukraine brauchen wir deeskalation
abrüstung viel mehr diplomatie
interessenausgleich auch das gegenüber
hat ja interessen und endlich die
strikte warnung des völkerrechts von
allen seiten
gregor gysi war das von der
linksfraktion hat hier unter anderem von
der afg fraktion von der spd und von den
grünen zwischendrin applaus bekommen zum
schluss hat dann aber nur noch eine
fraktion applaudiert nächster redner ist
aus der fdp-fraktion alexander müller
manchmal ist es nötig von dieser stelle
aus einmal zu erklären was der
unterschied zwischen einem
parlamentarischen untersuchungsausschuss
gemäß artikel 44 unserer verfassung und
eine enquete kommission ist ein
untersuchungsausschuss arbeitet explizit
mit dem mittel der beweisaufnahme so
steht es wörtlich im artikel 44 es ist
ein mittel zur aufarbeitung politischer
verantwortung und den schuldfragen eine
enquete kommission arbeitet auf
wissenschaftlicher basis hier wird mit
den erkenntnissen und den erfahrungen
aus der vergangenheit an der zukunft
gearbeitet
die antrag stellen der afd verteufelt
den bundeswehreinsatz in afghanistan in
gänze dabei verschweigt sie dass die
bundeswehr im jahr 2001 im rahmen von
nato beschlossen aufgrund der
bündnisverpflichtungen im artikel 5
zusammen mit allen nato partnern am
einsatz teilnehmen musste
wären wir damals nicht mitgegangen wären
wir heute nicht mehr in der nato
offensichtlich ist dies die intentionen
der antragstellenden afd wladimir putin
ist dieser partei immer wieder zu großem
dank verpflichtet
aber liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
afghanistan einsatz begann zehn jahre
vor der gründung der fdp
inzwischen fragen eine erlaubnis nicht
trotzdem wird uns diese fraktion hier
erklären dass man schon immer gewusst
hätte dass unsere teilnahme am einsatz
schon immer ein grundlegender fehler
gewesen sei wie anmaßend ist diese
einstellung mit dem wissen von heute
wollen sie diejenigen verurteilen die
vor 20 jahren in einer akuten lage
brutalster terroranschläge eine
entscheidung treffen mussten osama bin
laden und seine schergen von al qaida
lebten dort in afghanistan und wurden
von der damaligen taliban regierung
toleriert und produziert von dort aus
haben sie in der ganzen welt
hochkomplexe und blutigste terror
anschläge auf zivilisten geplant und
exekutiert die u bahn anschläge von
madrid und london
der unvorstellbar brutaler anschlag auf
das world trade center die tausenden von
getöteten unschuldigen zivilisten all
das wollte die afg offensichtlich
dauerhaft in kauf nehmen um die
terrorbanden in afghanistan nicht dabei
zu stören wie zynisch ist das wenn sie
in ihrem antrag behaupten der zitat der
westliche eingriff in afghanistan sei er
friedens hammond als förderlich gewesen
diese üble geschichtsklitterung sagen
sie den waisenkindern und witwen des 11
september 2001 ins gesicht es ist
wirklich zum schämen
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die große
koalition hat die mission report auch
aus meiner sicht viel zu wenig evaluiert
und hat sie immer wieder unverändert
verlängert ohne sich einmal selbst zu
hinterfragen ohne erfolge misserfolge
und auswirkungen gründlich auszuwerten
und die eigene strategie haben wir zu
überprüfen ich selbst habe daher in den
letzten vier jahren nur ein einziges mal
eine verlängerung von resolution
zugestimmt danach nie mehr weil auch ich
nicht mehr von diesem einsatz überzeugt
war aber deswegen bin ich besonders
dankbar dass unsere koalition eine
gründliche aufarbeitung des
afghanistan-einsatzes vornimmt und zwar
so wie es geboten ist die klärung der
verantwortung für die damalige situation
der ortskräfte der fatalen lage
fehleinschätzungen im august 20 21 das
evakuierungs chaos in einem
parlamentarischen untersuchungsausschuss
wo sie ihre fragen stellen können und
nebenbei parallel die wissenschaftliche
aufarbeitung der lehren aus dem einsatz
also was man mit einem auslandseinsatz
grundsätzlich erreichen kann und was
nicht im rahmen einer enquete kommission
das ist genau der richtige ansatz und so
haben wir es im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart beide gremien enquete und
untersuchungsausschuss starten in diesem
sommer mit ihrer arbeit wir freuen uns
daher auf eine breite zustimmung für
dieses vorgehen in diesem haus vielen
dank
herr kollege müller
die fdp fraktion hat eine
kurzinterventionen beantragt dass die
letzte die zu diesem themenkomplex zu
lassen werde von der fraktion der
kollege wunder hat das wort
ja werte herr kollege müller einfach nur
um der historischen wahrheit
den raum zu geben als einer der schon
2001 befasst war mit der thematik
einfach nur als statement die
beteiligung deutschlands an den isaf
einsatz war im ersten jahr kein nato
einsatz der einsatz wurde am 22 dezember
wenn ich das richtig erinnere durch den
damaligen bundeskanzler schröder
entschieden als teilnahme an einer
collection of the village das ist
einfach der historische hintergrund
vielen dank
herr kollege müller wollen sie antworte
ich sehe sie wollen also haben sie das
recht sein wird
danke für die belehrung herr kollege
wohn truck ich wusste gar nicht dass sie
im jahr 2001 2002 hier auch schon mit in
der verantwortung waren
die afg hat mit diesem einsatz mit
diesem antrag den gesamten afghanistan
einsatz infrage gestellt in bausch und
bogen verurteilt und damit macht das
wenig unterschied ob er ein jahr später
auf nato bitte hin gefahren sind oder
nicht wenn sie wenn sie den einsatz so
komplett infrage stellen macht das
keinen unterschied mehr
vielleicht darf ich noch darauf
hinweisen dass die bundeswehr eine
parlamentsarmee ist und der
bundeskanzler selbst keine eigene
entscheidung treffen kann für aussagen
sind nur das parlament selbst die
deutsche öffentlichkeit nicht im
falschen angelegt
nochmal hier die erläuterung von
bundestags vizepräsident wolfgang
kubicki das natürlich zuerst immer eine
abstimmung des parlaments erfolgen muss
bevor die bundeswehr in einen einsatz
fährt rebecca schambach spricht jetzt
für die spd-fraktion
werter herr präsident liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen sehr geehrte damen und
herren
jeden morgen geht mein erster blick zu
den meldungen was ist passiert in der
welt natürlich ist gerade der
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine im
medialen und unser aller fokus aber wir
dürfen die anderen krisen dieser welt
nicht vergessen auch aus afghanistan
kommen stetig besorgniserregende meldung
ich fälle exemplarisch zwei nennen uns
95 prozent der menschen in afghanistan
haben nicht genug zu essen gerade kinder
und jugendliche sind besonders betroffen
es kommt auch medienberichten sogar
immer häufiger vor dass eltern eines
ihrer kinder
verkaufen um die übrigen ernähren zu
können und von nicht einmal zwei wochen
war überall zu lesen die taliban haben
verordnet dass frauen sich in der
öffentlichkeit wieder vollkommen zu
verschleiern haben die meldungen zum
leid in afghanistan scheint sich immer
mehr zu verdichten darum möchte ich an
dieser stelle zuerst ganz klar sagen wir
werden unser engagement für die
bevölkerung vor ort fortsetzen es ist
schwierig ja aber das darf uns nicht
abhalten
des weiteren müssen die lehren aus der
vergangenheit aus dem 20 jährigen
bundeswehreinsatz in afghanistan ziehen
aufklären und aufarbeiten und das auch
ganz selbstkritisch mit einer am ende
ehrlichen bilanz dafür haben wir uns als
koalitionsfraktionen vorgenommen sowohl
einen untersuchungsausschuss als auch
einer enquete kommission einzusetzen um
unabhängig missstände in der exekutiven
aufzudecken und das fehlverhalten von
verantwortlichen zu überprüfen beide
untersuchungsgremium werden eigene
schwerpunkte setzen und sich doch
ergänzen damit geht unser aufklärungs
vorhaben noch weit über die forderung
der opposition der afg hinaus ist
präziser und aus meiner sicht auch
logischer und
ich frage mich ohnehin ist gern hier
schon mehrfach angeklungen wozu die afd
einen untersuchungsausschuss beantragen
will wenn sie schon im antragstext
unterstellt das ergebnis bereits zu
kennen bei dann bräuchte es keinen
untersuchungsausschuss mehr somit hat
die fdp ihren eigenen antrag überflüssig
gemacht uns als spd ist eine unabhängige
und umfassende aufklärung hingegen
wichtig die abgeordnete tragen gegenüber
den einsatzkräften eine besondere
verantwortung sie künftig besser zu
schützen und keine keinen unnötigen
gefahren auszusetzen als
verteidigungspolitikerin ist mir das ein
besonderes anliegen der einsatz in
afghanistan war eine zäsur
so beschreibt es die wehrbeauftragte in
ihrem aktuellen bericht
59 soldaten starben in afghanistan viele
weitere müssen bis heute mit
körperlichen und psychischen folgen
lieben ich sehe es als meine aufgabe an
dass wir im parlament aufklären welche
fehler ist bei diesem auslandseinsatz
gegeben hat damit wir sie in zukunft bei
anderen einsätzen vermeiden können die
bundeswehr hat allerdings in afghanistan
auch gezeigt was sie zu leisten imstande
ist in kürzester zeit nämlich in nur elf
tagen ist es ihr gelungen
mehr als 5000 menschen nach deutschland
in sicherheit zu bringen diese
evakuierungs mission war schwierig und
extrem gefährlich
es war eine enorme leistung unserer
streitkräfte und aus gesprächen mit der
truppe mit einzelnen soldatinnen und
soldaten weiß ich dass sie alles ihnen
mögliche getan haben um so viele
menschen wie möglich zu retten und ich
bin fest davon überzeugt dass sie sie
hätten gerne noch mehr getan
ich kann mich noch gut daran erinnern
als der letzte a400m mit dieser
rettungsaktionen auf dem fliegerhorst in
wünsdorf landete zu diesem zeitpunkt war
ich noch nicht abgeordnete sondern
bürgerinnen im nachbarort von wunstorf
welches heute zu meinem wahlkreis zählt
durch diese örtliche nähe kenne ich
einige soldatinnen und soldaten auch
piloten und habe diese zeit sehr
emotional miterlebt mir ist es jetzt als
parlamentarier ein bedürfnis und ich bin
froh über diese gelegenheit hier heute
nochmal unserer parlamentsarmee für
diesen einsatz herzlich danke zu sagen
und ein besonderer gruß und dank geht
natürlich an das lufttransportgeschwader
62 nach wunstorf
jetzt macht schon mal einmal ganz
ausdrücklich wir werden diesen einsatz
aufarbeiten und unsere schlüsse daraus
ziehen dafür läuft es keinen unlogischen
antrag der fdp-fraktion den wir
natürlich ablehnen werden herzlichen
dank
nächster redner in dieser debatte zu
einem antrag der fdp-fraktion di fordert
einen untersuchungsausschuss einzusetzen
zum afghanistan-einsatz ist florian hahn
der verteidigungspolitische sprecher der
unions-fraktion ja sehr geehrter herr
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
mit der rückkehr der letzten deutschen
soldaten aus afghanistan am 27 august
endete das deutsche militärische
engagement in afghanistan
und wir haben uns hier im hohen haus
lange und ausführlich beispielsweise
auch über den satz
ausgetauscht und diskutiert nichts sei
gut in afghanistan
wir müssen leider feststellen mit blick
auf den rückzug und die entwicklung
danach und das haben die kolleginnen und
kollegen ja schon an deiner oder anderen
stellt deutlich gemacht nichts des
besser geworden in afghanistan und das
schmerzt sehr
die bilder der damaligen internationalen
evakuierungs mission aus kabul gingen um
die welt und sie die evakuierung selbst
stellt einen abschluss da wir dürfen
jedoch nicht vergessen was am anfang
stand und unser engagement in
afghanistan ausgelöst hat und notwendig
gemacht hat und das waren die
fürchterlichen terrorakte in new york
und in washington vom 11 september
2001 und mit diesem engagement das über
die gesamte zeit von breiten
parlamentarischen mehrheit getragen
wurde haben unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten unter schwierigen bedingungen
20 jahre lang einen anerkannten beitrag
zur sicherheit und zum fähigkeit aufbau
in afghanistan geleistet das gleiche
gilt für unsere diplomaten sowie für
zahlreiche zivile entwicklungshelfer
staatliche aber auch nichtstaatliche um
meine damen und herren zur wahrheit
gehört der versuch der internationalen
gemeinschaft frieden und demokratie nach
afghanistan zu bringen war auch lange
sicht leider nicht von erfolg gekrönt
zur wahrheit gehört eben aber auch in
der zeit des internationalen
militärischen engagement gegen von
afghanistan keine terroristische
bedrohung für europa und die westliche
welt aus und deshalb kann und muss man
festhalten deutschland ist mit der
bundeswehr nicht spektakulär gescheitert
wie es im afg antrag heißt die
bundeswehr hat die aufträge die ihr von
der politik erteilt worden sind in
afghanistan erfüllt und unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten haben ihre
pflicht erfüllt 59 davon dafür das
größte opfer gebracht dass man erbringen
kann und auch deshalb finde ich es
unredlich dass sie in ihrem antrag die
bundeswehr und konkret die leistungen
unserer soldatinnen und soldaten in 20
jahren afghanistan in nicht mal mit
einer silbe ansprechen unsere
unsere truppe
sie machen sie machen sie machen diesen
fehler nicht besser mit ihrem geschrei
unsere truppe verdient nämlich
anerkennen nicht nur von der
gesellschaft sondern auch aus dem
parlamentarischen raum und das gilt für
links aus sondern es gilt eben auch für
rechtsaußen und herr gysi sie hatten
heute die große chance nach 20 jahren
zum ersten mal in diesem parlament zu
sagen welche leistungen die bundeswehr
im namen dieses parlaments tatsächlich
geleistet hat und sich zu bedanken und
auch diese chance haben sie wieder
einmal liegen lassen
mit dem vorliegenden mit dem
vorliegenden antrag meine damen und
herren von der afg machen sie deutlich
dass es der afg nicht um eine ernsthafte
aufarbeitung wird dieser antrag der fdp
r der afg ist eine eine reine show sie
haben es ja förmlich darauf angelegt
dass dieser antrag abgelehnt wird sonst
hätten sie sich mehr mühe gegeben um
zumindest die formalen voraussetzungen
zu erfüllen dass dieser antrag
tatsächlich überhaupt positiv abgestimmt
werden kann dazu gehört zb dass der
antrag das ergebnis des geforderten
untersucht geforderten untersuchung
schon vorwegnimmt und dies zeigt doch
dass es ihnen eben nicht um aufklärung
geht sie möchten mit diesem
untersuchungsausschuss
politisches kapital schlagen und das am
ende auf rücken unserer soldatinnen und
soldaten und herr brandner ihre
unqualifizierten und niveaulosen
ständigen zwischen schreierei hat das
auch noch mal deutlich unterstrichen
die weltweiten krisen werden künftig
eher zu als abnehmen nicht alle werden
sich mit diplomatie lösen lassen wir
werden damit nicht umhin kommen wieder
soldatinnen und soldaten möglicherweise
in einsätze zu schicken und diese
soldaten und soldatinnen schulden wir es
jetzt die richtigen schlüsse aus den
vergangenen 20 jahren am hindukusch zu
ziehen meine damen und herren deshalb
ist doch klar unser engagement
afghanistan muss aufgearbeitet werden
die afghanistan- einsatz bedarf einer
umfassenden evaluierung ein
parlamentarischer untersuchungsausschuss
ist jedoch unstreitig das falsche mittel
um das ressort übergreifende deutsche
engagement in afghanistan
im rückblick angemessen und würdig zu
beleuchten und schon gar nicht so wie es
sich die afg vorstellt der vorliegende
antrag liest sich eher wie die forderung
nach einem tribunal das lehnen wir
entschieden ab
billiger
ist ja kollege julian park bündnis 90
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte demokratinnen wir alle erinnern
uns an die bilder bilder aus dem letzten
sommer verzweifelte menschen die mit
allen mitteln versuchen die stadt zu
durchqueren um den kabuler flughafen zu
erreichen die sich auf dem rollfeld
drängen die versuchen in eines der
wenigen flugzeuge zu kommen die bilder
aus dem innenraum einer amerikanischen
maschine in der menschen dicht an dicht
auf dem boden covern und ja auch das
grausame bild von menschen die aus dem
radkasten eines flugzeugs fällen in
deutschland haben sich zehntausende für
die aufnahme dieser menschen eingesetzt
mit rettungsaktion demos und hektisch
geführten listen mit gefährdeten
menschen die evakuiert werden sollen und
von dem bis heute viele in afghanistan
um ihr leben bangen elf tage dauerte die
deutsche mission und menschen
auszufliegen dann war die evakuierung
beendet viele viele menschen bleiben
verzweifelt zurück und damit auch viele
fragen warum hat die bundesregierung der
letzten koalition dieses versagen nicht
verhindert warum wurde nicht früher
gehandelt wie so wurden die zivilen
rettungsaktionen vielleicht nicht
ausreichend unterstützt dieses
historische versagen wird ein
parlamentarischer untersuchungsausschuss
aufarbeiten und es ist eine besondere
größe dass sie liebe kollegin von der
spd dieses anliegen teilen wir sind uns
einig dass wir aus den fehlern der
gescheiterten evakuierungs mission
lernen müssen denn vielen gefährdeten
menschen die deutsche regierung in
afghanistan im stich gelassen hat
schulden wir nicht nur die einsetzung
dieses untersuchungsausschusses denn wir
haben auch eine moralische verpflichtung
im rahmen unserer möglichkeiten den
menschen zu helfen die sich für ein
demokratisches und rechtsstaatliches
aufgaben afghanistan eingesetzt haben
und jetzt genau deswegen akut gefährdet
sind
wir haben im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart eine manie theres
aufnahmeprogramm einzusetzen dieses
aufnahmeprogramm muster situation in
afghanistan gerecht werden denn dort
verstecken sich seit monaten weiterhin
männer frauen und kinder vor der gewalt
der taliban um dem tod zu entgehen und
diese menschen können im wahrsten sinne
des wortes nicht mehr länger war und
während diese bundesregierung daran
arbeitet akut gefährdete menschen aus
afghanistan aufzunehmen fantasiert die
fdp möglichst schnell wieder menschen in
die gewaltherrschaft der taliban
abgeschoben werden können wir lesen doch
täglich neue berichte über anschläge
hinrichtungen und die hasserfüllte
unterdrückung von frauen und mädchen die
afd aber fordert im ernst dieses regime
der taliban anzuerkennen das ist der
wahre geist dieser partei die zur
erfüllung ihrer rassistischen fantasien
selbst mit der taliban kooperieren würde
wir sind uns unserer verantwortung
bewusst und diese gesellschaft ist es
auch wie stehen zur verantwortung um die
aufklärung genauso wie der zur aufnahme
denn unsere gesellschaft es bereits ein
sicherer hafen zu sein für gefährdete
afghanen denn die menschen in
afghanistan haben ein recht auf ein
leben würde in freiheit und
selbstbestimmung vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollege julian tacke
war das für bündnis 90 die grünen auf
ihn folgt jetzt an der rutsche jurisch
sie sitzt für die fdp fraktion im
ausschuss für die angelegenheiten der
europäischen union
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren
sie sind jetzt auf uns angewiesen so wie
wir damals auf sie angewiesen waren die
zahlreichen ortskräfte in afghanistan
haben großes geleistet für unser land
und unsere freiheit und sicherheit und
ganz besonders für unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten vor ort sie haben ihr leben
riskiert um die mitarbeitenden unserer
streitkräfte unseres diplomatischen
dienstes und unsere entwicklungshilfe
organisation bei der erfüllung ihrer
aufgaben zu unterstützen und dafür
schulden wir unseren partnerinnen und
partnern in afghanistan den orts kräften
unseren dank
wir werden den orts- kreis- und jan
unserer seite standen und auch ihren
gefährdeten familien ermöglichen in
sicherheit in deutschland zu leben und
das sollte nein muss eine
selbstverständlichkeit sein auch wenn
damit große logistische herausforderung
für uns verbunden sind als fortschritts
koalition sind wir angetreten um mutige
entscheidungen zu treffen um den
stillstand und das zögern hinter uns zu
lassen und wir sind angetreten mit einem
klaren bekenntnis für unsere ortskräfte
dass wir heute diese diskussion führen
haben wir eine offensichtlich
überstürzten und mutmaßlich
unkoordinierten evakuierungs mission zu
verdanken die deutsche botschaft wurde
offensichtlich sehr spät evakuiert
gerade einmal 1 138 afghanische
ortskräfte mit 496 angehörigen konnten
damals direkt ausgeflogen werden bis
heute sind etwa 3500 ortskräfte in
deutschland angekommen und auch immer
warten viele von den orts kräften und
ihre angehörigen in todesangst auf
unsere unterstützung ihre ausreise ist
aber jetzt ungleich schwerer als sie es
im letzten frühjahr gewesen wäre
zusammen mit unseren jetzigen
koalitionspartner von den grünen haben
wir uns schon in der vergangenen
wahlperiode dafür stark gemacht die
evakuierungs mission in allen facetten
lückenlos aufzuklären und wir werden
unser versprechen halten und möglichst
noch vor der sommerpause einen
untersuchungsausschuss einsetzen
ich werde mich persönlich dafür
einsetzen dass wir aufklären welche
potenziellen versäumnisse und
fehleinschätzungen und welches
mutmaßlich ausgebliebene handel nimmt
zum beispiel geschäftsbereich des
bundesministeriums für inneres zur
aktuellen lage geführt haben wir werden
uns dabei anschauen die
abstimmungsprozesse innerhalb der
damaligen bundesregierung und die
sachverhalte rund um visa und aufnahme
zu sagen insbesondere gilt es aber zu
beurteilen welche rolle wo möglich ich
falsche oder unzureichende informationen
des bundesnachrichtendienstes zu den
fehleinschätzungen und versäumnissen
geführt haben so dass ganz
offensichtlich kein geordneter abzug
damals mehr möglich war ein
untersuchungsausschuss aber wie sie ihn
hier vorschlagen ein bei denen es nur
darum geht jemand anzuschwärzen das ist
doch nicht zielführend
entscheidend wird am ende doch sein dass
wir konkrete lehren daraus ziehen aus
diesen abzugs geschehen vom letzten
sommer wir wollen doch sicherstellen
dass solche fehler in zukunft nicht mehr
gemacht werden
wir sind gewählt worden um die zukunft
zu gestalten um sicherzustellen dass
sich so etwas nicht mehr wiederholt und
mutiger zu sein und fortschritt zu
erzeugen und das geht nur mit dem blick
nach vorne und ich danke ihnen für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
als nächster hält das wort der kollegen
acker an dem ihr spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine sehr
geehrten kolleginnen und kollegen eine
kurze vorbemerkung in richtung fdp
fraktion sie haben dafür geworben dass
deutschland schnellstmöglich die taliban
anerkennt um wieder nach afghanistan
abschieben zu können und darum geht es
ihnen nicht um verantwortung und
menschenrechte oder frauenrechte wie sie
es hier am anfang gesagt haben und da
müsse damit es auch genug über die afg
und ihre solidarität mit der
afghanischen bevölkerung gesagt ich will
heute über verantwortung sprechen
verantwortung zu der die spd fraktion zu
der die regierung steht
liebe kolleginnen kollegen wir sind im
august gegangen doch geblieben sind
millionen von menschen darunter sind
zehntausende die in gefahr sind sie sind
in gefahr weil sie ein offenes und
solidarisches leben führen wollen sie
wurden nun den taliban überlassen und
einige von ihnen haben die taliban nicht
überlebt
ich erinnere an die frauenrechtlerin und
ökonomen froh sein safi sie wollte in
deutschland asyl beantragen doch während
sie bei ihrer familien afghanistan
schutz suchte und ihre ausreise
vorbereitete wurde sie in einen
hinterhalt gelockt und erschossen weil
sie eine frau war und nicht hinnehmen
wollte dass frauen nicht die gleichen
rechte haben
doch wir haben auch menschen retten
können bis april allein 15.800
ortskräfte und ihre familien an dieser
stelle danke ich dem
bundesinnenministerium und dem
auswärtigen amt für ihre bemühungen
menschen herauszuholen aufnahme zusagen
zu erteilen und viel vielen dank an die
soldatinnen und soldaten die evakuiert
kam
danke auch den mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern der kids und all der
beteiligten angeles ohne sie wäre eine
rettung oft nicht möglich gewesen wie im
fall von hamm etwa mieter in kabul seine
eigene modeagentur betrieb er arbeitete
mit männlichen und weiblichen models
experimentierte mit verschiedenen stilen
dafür dafür wurde er von den taliban
bedroht mit einer aufnahme zusage aus
deutschland konnte er aus afghanistan
evakuiert werden und fängt in berlin
jetzt ein neues leben an und
organisationen wie die kabel luftbrücke
haben nicht nur etwaige rettet sie
bringen immer noch täglich menschen auf
aus afghanistan heraus und damit in
sicherheit und ich weiß auch dass sie
gestern beispielsweise auch einen bus
über die grenze bringen konnten denn es
ist klar unsere verantwortung endet
nicht im august letzten jahres unsere
verantwortung geht weiter solange
menschen in gefahr sind sie endet auch
nicht wenn andere krisen unsere
aufmerksamkeit einnehmen so wie wir
heute solidarisch mit den geflüchteten
aus der ukraine sind so müssen wir es
auch mit den geflüchteten aus
afghanistan bleiben
deshalb werden wir sowohl für ortskräfte
als auch für andere gefährdete personen
die aufnahmen fortsetzen das ist unsere
verantwortung und es ist auch unsere
verantwortung zu untersuchen was bei der
evakuierung gut und schlecht gelaufen
ist dafür richten wir den
untersuchungsausschuss zur evakuierung
und die enquete-kommission zum gesamten
einsatz ein und wir werden auch lehren
für das ortskräfte verfahren ziehen denn
auch das ist unsere verantwortung
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir sind
im august gegangen doch geblieben sind
millionen von menschen darunter sind
zehntausende gegen den gefahr sind sie
sprechen vielleicht nicht unsere sprache
sie haben vielleicht nicht unseren pass
aber ihre gedanken und wünsche sind die
unseren sie wollen in freiheit leben
bücher lesen arbeiten zur schule gehen
anders gesagt sie sind in gefahr weil
sie wie wir sind deshalb hielt wir haben
eine verantwortung sie nicht im stich zu
lassen und das werden wir auch nicht
dankeschön
[Applaus]
einen schönen guten tag von meiner seite
und der nächste redner in dieser debatte
ist paul signac cdu/csu-fraktion
frau präsidentin zunächst einmal gute
besserung verehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen
ein starkes interfraktionelle zeichen an
dieser stelle frau präsidentin frau
präsidentin meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren bevor ich zum antrag der fdp
fraktion komme möchte ich auch für eine
aussprache am heutigen tag in dieser
debatte eingehen die ich finde wir nicht
so stehen lassen können herr doktor gysi
haben hier die einzelnen einsätze der
bundeswehr im ausland aufgezählt und
haben von fehlern gesprochen unter
anderem den einsatz der bundeswehr im
kosovo angesprochen es als fehler
bezeichnet dass die bundeswehr in den
kosovo gegangen ist erreicht hatte er
wird hier von den linken gerufen meine
damen und herren wir müssen uns doch in
diesem punkt eigentlich habe ich gedacht
der drg sie nicht streiten es war ein
völkermord es waren unglaubliche
verbrechen an der zivilbevölkerung im
kosovo und die rot grüne regierung die
initiative hat die initiative ergriffen
der deutsche bundestag auch mit stimmen
der union hat zugestimmt ich finde wir
können unseren soldatinnen und soldaten
dankbar sein dass sie das leben so
vieler menschen so viele kosovo albaner
1999 und danach gerettet haben meine
damen und herren und das ist auch ein
zeichen an alle
die einem auch sagen übrigens im ausland
diese dankbarkeit verspüren gegenüber
unseren soldatinnen und soldaten der
bundeswehr
wir als abgeordnete ich denke es ist
selbstverständlich für jeden
abgeordneten deutschen bundestages dass
er diesen respekt vor unseren
streitkräften hat
jetzt zu ihrem antrag es wurde mehrfach
gesagt was er ist ein show antrag
natürlich weil sie das vorweg nehmen was
eigentlich vielleicht bestandteil einer
untersuchung sein könnte es ist ein
populistischer show antrag er bestimmt
gar nicht den untersuchungsgegenstand
sondern er versucht
auf der tatsache des abzuges und da gibt
es es ist hier schon angesprochen worden
vieles was wir aufarbeiten müssen
versucht daraus einfach parteipolitik zu
machen ihm geht es um selbstprofilierung
geht es um parteipolitik in geht es um
show und nicht in wirklichkeit um die
frage wie wir in anderen zusammenhängen
bessere arbeit leisten können und sie
zeigen auch meine damen und herren immer
wieder als die fraktion dass es ihnen
weder um die bundeswehr noch um
afghanistan geht ihm geht es auch nicht
um nachhaltige entwicklungshilfe politik
das erleben wir jede woche im
entwicklungsausschuss
wir wissen sie gucken mich jetzt so an
wir wissen doch beide dass ihnen die
menschen ihnen sind die menschen ihn
sind die menschen in afghanistan völlig
egal dass wissen sie und das weist das
ganze haus und auch die öffentlichkeit
das ist so
das ist das ist nun mal so und deswegen
ist doch die frage
wo können sie eigentlich in beitrag
leisten einen untersuchungsausschuss
einzurichten und deswegen weil dieser
antrag sich von selbst eigentlich
erledigt und schon soviel dazu gesagt
wurde ich würde vorschlagen dass in
zusammenhang jetzt auch mit dem krieg in
der ukraine wieder einmal einen
untersuchungsausschuss einrichten um
ihre verbindung in den kreml mal genauer
zu untersuchen es gibt strategiepapiere
es gibt strategie es gibt
strategiepapiere aus moskau die sagen
ihre abgeordneten ihrer abgeordneten
stehen unter absoluter kontrolle sie
kennen ja die berichte die es dazu gibt
danke also ihre nervosität zeigt mir
dass diese berichte zutreffen sind
lassen sie uns das mal machen und wenn
sie einen antrag stellen die verbindung
der afg nach moskau mal genauer unter
die lupe zu nehmen dann werde ich mich
dafür einsetzen dass es der erste
gemeinsame antrag wird zu meiner
fraktion und ihrer vielen herzlichen
dank
paul signac war das mittlerweile hat
auch das präsidium gewechselt yvonne mag
was leitet jetzt hier die sitzung und
wir kommen auch schon zum vorletzten
redner in dieser debatte das system
trittin bewies 970
wenn in afghanistan jetzt wieder
burkhardt zwang herrscht wenn mädchen
daran gehindert werden höhere schulen zu
besuchen
dann ist das kein ergebnis wie sie
behauptet haben viel minister
außenpolitik sondern das ist eine
bittere niederlage in unserem streit für
universelle menschenrechte
aber es ist ja noch viel schlimmer sie
haben hier im satz gesagt
der einsatz in afghanistan hätte diesem
land eine andere kultur aufzwingen
wollen
ihre ihre vorstellung von kultur
beinhaltet also
burka zwang bildungs verweigerung für
schulen in dieses land wollen sie
menschen abschieben ich weiß nicht was
ekelhaft da ist ihr unchristlicher anti
muslime halten oder ihre offenkundige
frauenfeindlichkeit in diesem land
aber meine damen und herren ich glaube
dass demokratische spektrum dieses
hauses tut gut daran sich dieser frage
afghanistan mit ernsthaftigkeit zu
nähern
ernsthaftigkeit unter anderem auch
deswegen weil wir der auffassung sind
oder erleben müssen dass
militärische intervention
häufig auch gescheitert sind oder
probleme hinterlassen haben das gilt für
missionen an denen wir uns beteiligt
haben wie in afghanistan
das gilt für interventionen an denen
sich diese bundestag mit gutem grund
nicht beteiligt hat wie zb viren und
deswegen ist es wichtig diese geschichte
des afghanistan krieges und der
intervention aufzuarbeiten und dabei
müssen wir uns alle auch selber in frage
stehe
ich selber bin der auffassung ja es war
richtig
2001 dafür zu sorgen dass von
afghanistan aus diesem regime von osama
bin laden keine terroristische bedrohung
der welt mehr ausging und deswegen war
dieser einsatz in dem sinne richtig und
übrigens auch erfolgreich
ich muss mich aber auch fragen lassen
war eigentlich die phase des militärisch
zivilen ansatzes die wir gewählt haben
eigentlich sie will so ausgestattet dass
es funktionieren konnte konnte es
funktionieren das in einem raum in dem
eine stabilisierungsmission mit vielen
entwicklungs helferinnen und
entwicklungshelfern mit polizeibeamten
mit richtern und richtern die versucht
haben good governance beizubringen
eigentlich funktionieren wenn parallel
dazu ein volontär jede nacht
stattgefunden hat das sind fragen denen
wir uns für künftige einsätze stellen
müssen und es ist richtig
das ist ein komplett überstürzten
verantwortungslosen abzug gegeben hat
aber wir werden uns gemeinsam
konzipierte zum schluss frage stellen
müssen so präsident ich komme zum
schluss
ist dieses überstürzt sein vielleicht
ergebnis weil man nicht vor beginn von
rsm unter isaf in vernünftiger zeit
abgezogen ist und diese frage dreht ihre
das hat er ein untersuchungsausschuss
auf wären wir auf den weg bringen und
eine antragskommission und ich finde
dass ist die ernsthaftigkeit mit der man
sich diesem thema betrieb
und die letzte regeln letzte rednerin in
der debatte der iarc nach bauer spd
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren ein reisender will mit
dem flugzeug nach rom zu einer show
steht aber am fernbahnhof mit einem
busticket in der hosentasche und landet
dann irgendwie mit der u-bahn
unterirdisch in braunschweig
genauso verhält es sich mit diesem von
der afg gestellten antrag planlos
unkoordiniert ein sammelsurium an bild
zusammen gestellten fragen wir haben
einen plan ein koordinierten wir haben
uns nämlich in unserem koalitionsvertrag
klar dazu bekannt dass wir die
vergangenen geschehnisse rund um den
afghanistan-einsatz aufarbeiten wollen
und vor allem diesen unrühmlichen abzug
wir wollen einen untersuchungsausschuss
und dafür brauchen wir alle demokraten
keine hilfe von rechts außen vor allem
nicht von einer fraktion die an
herzlosigkeit kaum zu überbieten wenn
ihnen die lage in afghanistan ein
anliegen ist warum leben geht kein
einziges wort zu hunger und armut und
fehlender medizinischer versorgung kein
wort dazu darf menschenrechtsverstöße
und unsicherheit inzwischen den alltag
der menschen in afghanistan bringen
landesweit haben 18,8 millionen afghanen
nicht genug zu essen herr den sie mit
ihrem kaktus besonders dramatisch ist
die lage für 4,7 millionen kinder sowie
stillende und schwangere frauen
expertinnen gehen davon aus dass 98
prozent der bevölkerung in den nächsten
monaten unter die armutsgrenze fallen
wird von der situation der mädchen will
ich gar nicht erst reden sie wollen
keinen dort darüber reden uns treibt es
um wir sind uns all dieser tatsachen
schmerzlich bewusst wenn es nun um die
frage der aufarbeitung geht haben wir
als spd und als koalition eine klare
zielsetzung es geht um die schaffung
eines gesamtbildes in einem ganz
bestimmten und klar definierten zeitraum
der afghanistan mission wir wollen
fragen wie haben sich die
verantwortlichen in der ehemaligen
bundesregierung in bestimmten
entscheidungssituation
insbesondere im zusammenhang mit dem
abzug der bundeswehr und der ortskräfte
aus afghanistan verhalten wurden die
richtigen entscheidungen getroffen
wurden alle verfügbaren informationen
genutzt gab es verletzungen der
sorgfaltspflicht und all diese fragen
sollten sich auf einen abgrenzbaren
zeitraum beziehen weil haben sie eine
zwischenfrage aus der fdp-fraktion
von mir ist das auch mit der parcours
reden egal
wir wollen aber auch leben für die
zukunft sind deswegen werden wir nicht
nur einen untersuchungsausschuss
einsetzen sondern ebenfalls eine enquete
kommission allerdings kennen wir den
unterschied dieser beiden
parlamentarischen formate offenbar ist
ihnen dieser unterschied nicht bekannt
da sie die einzelnen inhalte im antrag
völlig durcheinander größe
der untersuchungsausschuss ist nicht
dazu da künftiges politisches handeln zu
beeinflussen oder dafür empfehlungen
abzugeben die sie haben ende ihres
antrags tun es werden darin
ausschließlich in der vergangenheit
liegende abgeschlossene sachverhalte
untersucht er ist ein kontrollinstrument
des bundestags gegenüber der regierung
ein hilfsorgan des parlaments und kein
darüber hinausgehend ermächtigt das
organ der strafverfolgung ich möchte
hofften im antrag enthalten zitat des
politologen münkler eingehender von
einem ende der ära des humanitären
interventionismus spricht ich empfinde
das als zutiefst menschenverachtend wenn
man einzelne vorgänge dazu
instrumentalisiert alle humanitär
geleiteten projekte der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit pauschal zu
verdammen liebe soldatinnen und soldaten
lieber ortskräfte lassen sie sich in
ihren wichtigen einsatz nicht mit
populistischen parolen schlecht reden
wir sind ihnen alle dankbar dafür
diesen menschen kann sich zugehört die
menschen erkannt haben und
wir sind und bleiben diesen soldatinnen
und soldaten dankbar danken konnte
zumindest 20 jahre lang ein transport
zum schluss eine ganze generation junger
frauen heranwachsen die entschlossen ist
für ihre rechte zu kämpfen
und an die menschen in afghanistan auch
wenn euer leid in der berichterstattung
kaum mehr vorkommt wir sind uns unserer
verantwortung bewusst ihr seid nicht
vergessen vielen dank
und ich schliesse die aussprache in der
fraktion l wird die überweisung der
vorlage auf drucksache 18 67 an den
ausschuss für wahlprüfung immunität und
geschäftsordnung vorgeschlagen gibt es
weitere so das war also die aussprache
hier